now to demi lovato who has revealed they
are non-binary
and are changing their pronouns to they
them moving forward
uh yeah the singer shared a series of
tweets and a video clip from their new
podcast 4d with demi lovato saying
they'd
come to understand that their gender
identity
after a lot of healing and
self-reflective work
over the past year and a half i've been
doing some healing and self-reflective
work
and through this work i've had the
revelation that i identify as non-binary
with that said i'll officially be
changing my pronouns to they them
i feel that this best represents the
fluidity i feel in my gender expression
and allows me to feel most authentic
and true to the person i both know i am
and still am discovering
i want to make it clear that i'm still
learning and coming into myself
and i don't claim to be an expert or a
spokesperson
i know this might be a new conversation
for many so i'm inviting my friend alok
someone i trust to spend time on this
platform alok is an author performer and
an important voice within the non-binary
community and beyond
their work to create visibility equality
and understanding
has inspired me on my healing journey
yeah and uh speaking with alok for an
in-depth chat demi got emotional while
opening up about the pressure to be
female in today's society
there's nothing more freeing for me than
to be
unattached to
a role that society wants me to play
because that i fully believe that
gender is just another boundary that
separates humanity from divine wisdom
if we were to
[Music]
look past these boundaries that separate
us
and come together the world would live
in so much harmony and so much unity
you know i've had thoughts where i'm
like there might be a time where i want
to wear a
full wig there might be a time where i
you know want to dress completely fem
presenting
and that doesn't mean that in that
moment i'm identifying as a woman it
just means that that's what i want to
wear in that moment
you know and i want people to understand
that just because i'm non-binary doesn't
mean
i'm not going to
dress the way i want
now in a series of tweets alongside
their announcement debbie writes
every day we wake up we are given
another opportunity and chance to be who
we want and wish to be
i've spent the majority of my life
growing in front of all of you you've
seen the good the bad and everything in
between
not only has my life been a journey for
myself i was also living for those on
the other side of the cameras
yeah and uh demi goes on to say this
today is a day
i am so happy to share more of my life
with you all
i'm proud to let you know that i
identify as a as
non-binary and will officially be
changing my pronouns today them moving
forward
i'm doing this for those out there that
haven't been able to share who they
truly
are with their loved ones please keep
living your truths and i know
and know i am sending so much love your
way
xox so braz what do you uh
what was your initial reaction to this
announcement
i don't want demi lovato to die and
we have seen we have seen over the years
over my lifetime i shouldn't even see
over recent years over my lifetime
somebody who has dealt with incredible
addiction and rehab
and even everything that demi lovato has
gone through which is
dying um and then they build
distractions
into their recovery and we forget that
they're still in recovery you know they
got a new
uh music video they have a new movie
they have a new tour they get in a feud
they do all of this stuff
and we just jump on thinking everything
is okay and
demi lovato whatever is going on needs
to be
100 directly related to the recovery
process
and if that's what this is then power to
them
because again the only thing i want is
for demi lovato to stay alive
and i refuse to do this again where we
pretend that everything is fine
because what addicts tend to do is and
why this is concerning
i know a lot of the i know a lot of the
criticism today was
demi lovato comes out as an attention
seeker and all this stuff and i and i
and
my head didn't go there um where my head
went is when you're dealing
yeah yeah and yeah and they talked about
that
in the in the podcast too and i think
that they did a really great job sort of
covering off that criticism
but when you're dealing with somebody
who is dealing with addiction and you're
on the outside
one thing that you see over and over and
over again is they will come up with
justifications for the addiction
and a lot of times the justifications
for the addiction are easily fixable
and so they come out now and say this
was such a part of why i was
all those things but now i've managed to
fix it i've come to terms with it
and then we're all led to believe that
this is part of the
recovery process when really it is just
an a distraction
that uh that addicts do and again i say
this from the heart
and i'm not criticizing i just don't
want demi lovato to die and i think that
we all need especially the people
in her inner circle need to keep their
eye on that
yeah jessalyn's saying they're taking
small steps which is inspiring for
others
uh paige's saying i'm happy demi's
figuring things out
um and brian's saying hey everyone show
some love because as you were saying
yeah there's definitely comments
there's you know there's just a lot of
confusion that i'm reading
right now people don't always understand
things but it doesn't really matter this
is
this is how they feel and uh i'm happy
for demi i i
am because as you have said we've seen
ups and downs throughout her whole life
and or for their whole life and it's
it's just
uh my heart goes out to dummy growing up
as uh you know a little child in this
industry constantly being
told how to act how to dress how to how
to come across it's
a pressure that we'll never understand
um so if this is demi's
new journey and this is something that
she that they will explore see i'm
getting i'm getting the pronouns i'm
working on it
um it's been a day it's been a day
you're okay we'll get there it's been a
day
i'm very aware i wanna i wanna you know
obviously i know i know nobody nobody
nobody thinks you're not nobody thinks
you're trying to be correct it's okay
yeah so anyway very happy for demi
that's that i just i again again my eyes
my eyes are always on the recovery
and we've just we've just seen this too
many times and
um we've heard over the last little
while especially after the documentary
that there's some people in her inner
circle that are
genuinely concerned with the sort of
path that she's taken
to recover and that needs to be the
priority at all times regardless of
anything else